♪ ♪
>> Sean: NOW BAKE
BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AS OUR VERY OWN
SARA CARTER HAS AN EXCLUSIVE
HANNITY INVESTIGATION REVEALING
THE DANGEROUS REALITY OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND SMUGGLING UNDER
THE BIDEN ORDER CRISIS.
AND SHE JOINS US NOW TO EXPLAIN
A LOT MORE, A LOT GOING ON DOWN
THERE.
>> OH, YEAH, SURELY IS, SEAN AND
JUST GOT WRENCHING AND
HEARTBREAKING.
AS PART OF AN ONGOING DOCUSERIES
PROJECT THAT I AM WORKING ON AND
SPENT MORE THAN A WEEK AND
CENTRAL AMERICA RECENTLY.
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INTERVIEW A HUMAN TRAFFICKER.
IT WAS A VERY TENUOUS AND KIND
OF DANGEROUS SITUATION.
I WAS HESITANT AT FIRST TO DO
THE INTERVIEW, ALTHOUGH I DID
WANT TO FIND OUT MORE
INFORMATION, AND HE WANTED TO
SPEAK WITH ME.
ACTUALLY BECAUSE OF THE NUMBER
OF CHILDREN, WE KNOW HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN ARE BEING
TRAFFIC FROM CENTRAL AMERICA ALL
THE WAY TO THE WORLD IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AND EVEN WITH HUMAN TRAFFICKERS
CANNOT BEAR WHAT WAS HAPPENING
TO THEM AND THAT'S WHY HE TALKED
TO ME.
I WANT YOU TO TAKE A LISTEN THAN
THIS.
>> WHAT DO YOU DO FOR A LIVING?
>> I AM THE GUY WHO TAKES PEOPLE
TO THE U.S.
>> WHAT MADE YOU DECIDE TO DO
IT?
>> I LIKE TO TAKE THE RISK OF
DOING IT AND I KNEW THAT PEOPLE
WOULD GET A LOT OF MONEY OUT OF
IT.
>> SO YOU HAVE AN ENTIRE ROUTE
THE ORGANIZATION CONTROLS FROM
OUTSIDE TO THE UNITED STATES?
IS IT EASIER TO TRAFFIC THE
CHILDREN AND GET THEM IN THAN
THE ADULTS?
>> IT IS MORE RISKY, BECAUSE
ONCE WE GET THERE THEY ARE
ASKING FOR CHILDREN TO BE
TRAFFIC WITH DRUGS AND
EVERYTHING.
>> WHAT IS IT THAT WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND?
WHAT IS IT THAT IS SO BAD ABOUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE THINK OF IT LIKE THE
TRAFFICKING OF HUMAN BEINGS, THE
NARCOTICS THAT PEOPLE JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND?
>> IN THE CASE OF CHILDREN, IT
REALLY SCARES HIM TO JUST SEE
THE REALITY THAT THEY CAN GO
THROUGH AND FOR HIM IT IS PRETTY
HORRIFIC TO SEE HOW THEY ARE
MURDERED IN MANY CASES.
>> ARE THEY THEY JUST SO
POWERFUL NOW THAT IT IS GOING TO
BE --
IT'S GOING TO RESULT IN AN
ALL-OUT WAR IN AN EFFORT TO STOP
IT?
IS IT JUST --
ARE THEY JUST SO POWERFUL THAT
IT IS GOING TO BE IMPOSSIBLE FOR
ANY ONE PERSON TO STOP IT?
>> THERE IS NO WAY.
THEY ALREADY HAVE SO MUCH POWER
THAT IT'S TOO LATE TO STOP THEM.
>> SEAN, AND THERE IS SO MUCH
MORE THAT HE WENT INTO.
WE WILL GO INTO THAT IN
PART 2 COMING TO YOU TOMORROW.
BUT JUST ON MONDAY A 5-YEAR-OLD
GIRL LOST HER LIFE IN THE
RIO GRANDE RIVER.
HER MOTHER WAS TRYING TO GO
ACROSS WITH HER AND WAS HOLDING
HER IN HER ARMS AND LIKE PEOPLE
WARNED ALL THE TIME, THE
UNDERCURRENT WAS SO STRONG IT
SWEPT THE YOUNG CHILD FROM HER
ARMS.
ANOTHER BABY ALMOST DROWNED,
THAT BABY IS IN THE INTENSIVE
CARE UNIT AS WELL HERE AT
SAN ANTONIO, TEXAS, IN THE
HOSPITAL, BUT I HAD TO TELL YOU,
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN DISAPPEAR
ALL THE TIME EVEN BEFORE THEY
MAKE IT TO THE RIO GRANDE RIVER.
MANY OF THEM WILL NEVER BE
FOUND.
MANY OF THEM THEIR NAMES WILL
NEVER BE KNOWN.
WHEN WE BRING YOU THE SECOND
PART TOMORROW, IT IS VERY
DISTURBING.
IT IS VERY GRAPHIC.
AND THERE WERE INSTANCES IN THAT
INTERVIEW THAT I HAD NO IDEA
WHAT WAS HAPPENING TO THESE
CHILDREN.
FAR BEYOND THE KIDNAPPING, FAR
BEYOND THE SEXUAL PREDATORS.
I THINK EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD
KNOW WHAT IS HAPPENING.
AND NOT ONLY ON NATIONAL